every woman you see in this room has
been raped some are still young
teenagers and look at the response when
asked if they'd been raped more than
once almost every woman puts up their
hand in fact many of them raped multiple
times every woman here has a horrifying
experience of almost unimaginable
violence and this at the hands of
government soldiers rebel militias and
the vigilante groups set up to protect
the civilians they live together in a
small shelter run by Rebecca Masika
after being rejected by their families
and communities
mama seeker as she's known understands
the trauma of rape she's been raped
several times if you look at my face she
says you can see the scar it's a mark of
rape and I have them all over my body I
had to help these women because I've
been raped too they made me watch them
cut my husband's body into pieces then
they raped me on his dead body in the
group of women she cares for there are
several pregnant with the babies of
their rapists anurita is 16 years old
barely an adult and carrying a child
conceived out of torture she has a
weeping sores where the rebels sliced
her one of the many times during the
four months she was captive she has
terrible internal injuries to her birth
won't be easy they took us into the bush
she says and those who refuse to sleep
with them they forced by stabbing us
with knives they killed many of the
girls some of them are shot with bullets
in the vagina
many like de songs go on to reject their
rape babies my get the Emma have Billy
Matt have been it's totally affected me
she says I have a baby from the first
time I was raped but I don't love this
child I want nothing to do with you I
think every man who wears a uniform the
shelter itself isn't safe many of the
women hiding here were raped again when
m23 rebels stormed the house last year
chance safari was one she already had a
four-month-old rape baby when she was
violated again they didn't only rape
they looted and stole from us the baby
was in my bed wrapped up in blankets and
they didn't realize he was there they
just took all the blankets with the baby
inside and the next day we found the
baby thrown away and a waste tip he was
very ill and had broken ribs after being
thrown and he died soon afterwards to
see just a small outcome of these mass
rapes look at some of the children born
out of this violence a whole generation
congos civil war maybe 20 years old but
the raping and brutality is still
creating young victims mama seeker looks
after these young ones many of whom are
abandoned by their traumatized mothers
she gets no funding but exists on
donations she does however get death
threats from those she accuses of these
crimes
Kamara knew I wasn't in America they
wrote me letters and told me they'll
come a day when we shall come and rape
you in the nose the ears the mouth in
your eyes wherever there's a hole in the
human body we will rape you because
you're wrongly accusing us and telling
Western journalists that we are the
people who are raping and these people
who are threatening me she says are men
in uniform they're men in authority
wearing suits but carrying guns and
speaking the Rwandan language
their testimonies are difficult hearing
and terrible viewing but these women
believe ignoring these crimes is just
what their perpetrators want you to do
georgette as another who's been raped
several times and her tormentors don't
want you to see her scars she strips off
to show how her rapist stabbed her
breasts and then set fire to her body
it's a miracle they mutilated me and
tortured me they took a knife to me and
burned me even my genitals
there were 10 of them who tied me down
and took turns my body was perishing I
had worms coming out of me mamacita's
work is untold and mostly unknown
outside her community but the youngsters
and the women she counsels and cares for
are hanging on to hope because of her
out of Congo's chaotic civil war there
are far too many rape babies and rape
victims but mama seeker has shown there
are heroines to Alex Crawford Sky News
in the Democratic Republic of Congo